first up tom brady's got it all for NFL
championships a supermodel wife even a
cameo in the film Ted 2 which is a big
achievement
the Patriots QB is headed to his seventh
Super Bowl but espy nation reports that
when asked for comment on the refugee
crisis created by the Muslim ban Brady
replied quote what's going on in the
world I haven't paid much attention I'm
just a positive person so what's that
big election everyone's talking about
gonna happen what white privilege I've
never heard of it anyway
comedians Tom Brady's obviously been
distracted prepping for this big
footballing game catch him up on the
news and one sentence Whitney
so in football terms it's like if Donald
Trump was the quarterback but instead of
throwing to the receiver he's Hitler so
all anyone needs to know is we won you
snowflake limp hard cuts we're making
America great again huh no no no not so
much here I'm sorry I'm so sorry I got
that wrong Paul Scheer dude imagine if
Roger Goodell was the president
[Applause]